good morning millennials happy thursday
welcome back to the morning toast i am
joined by the most beautiful gorgeous
girlie of all time what is this glam
that we're looking at hello jacqueline
happy thursday everyone yes i look
stunning um i've been up since the crack
of dawn me and ben i literally just got
home four seconds ago we filmed an
episode of the good dish on cbs
and the episode airs next week i'll make
sure everyone knows when it airs we were
doing like spritz cocktails it was
really fun
and it was just really early so that's
why i'm in like full glam
you look so beautiful so since it was a
spritz related episode did you drink
that early in the morning i did i and we
were making like grapefruit tequila
cocktails and they were like really good
um so i'm a little lit i'm a little
tired i'm gorgeous as [ __ ]
um and i think it's a pretty good way to
start the thursday i'm not gonna lie
yeah no i can't believe it's thursday
this is my second to last show
and that's a lot that's a lot i've been
thinking about it here i know i'm really
even though with every day this week
like
my battery my human battery is literally
like on
zero and i slept really poorly last
night it's as if i didn't sleep at all
so i'm just like running on fumes um
so even though i'm like ready to take
the break and i don't know how much more
i can give i
am going to miss you guys dearly
us we're shy us
you i really am i mean i love the toast
so much i mean i guess tomorrow i'll say
my farewells even though it's literally
one month i calm down um yeah but i just
i love doing the show and i'm really
gonna miss it and i'm excited for this
next chapter and this next chapter
includes toast
thoroughly
but
it's just things are changing you know
and it's been it's been a nice
it's been a nice four years
as they were don't say that
you don't know like as seem like as they
were like we had four like like but then
things change
you know yeah
just they're not gonna change too much
right no no no but like i'm changing
you are changing
you know
you're not a girl not yet a woman
we're all changing so i'm just i'm
excited for what this chapter brings and
it's also crazy to think about the fact
that aside from like a few months that i
got off like
around april like i've really been um in
lockdown for two years
and i really look forward to emerging
and having other things to talk about
other than like being in my home
tv and piano and knitting and stuff no
but like two years worth of podcasting
every day with really no [ __ ] life
yeah it's a marvel it's a marvel it's
that it is a marvel
so i'm excited to have a life again and
to be able to share that with you
and
do what we do
well let's not be sad okay let's be
happy we've got a great show for
everyone we've got the fast five we've
got real housewives of orange county
recap um so there's tons of content and
let's just not be sad
who's sad we're just remarking on the
time that we're in we are acknowledging
the space that we're in and isn't that
what we always promised to do yeah but
you're just like remarking and
acknowledging on like something sad that
like you're leaving for a month so
well you get a month off you get to tour
you get to see all the toasters you get
to see this great country like what's
bad
no nothing's bad and reminder tickets
available at girlwithnojob.com in case
anyone had forgotten
i actually needed to know something
about your tour and i was like i was
like i could text you or i could go to
girl with no job.com sure and get the
information that i need which i did and
it was extremely helpful
literally anytime someone's like when is
your la show i'm like just give me one
second girls.com i use my own website as
my schedule it's like my calendar yeah
no that's how i use it to keep track of
you too i'm like where would she be on
this day people are like you want to
plan a trip for the first week of april
i'm like let me just go to girl with no
job tour first
that's funny well also i caught up on
the gilded age i think that you did too
so we could recap that at the end
because it's really it's really a
beautifully done nice show like the
opening credits stunning
stunning i will never be skipping that
intro ever and the third episode really
amped up some of the drama like it got
crazy at the end yeah so i'm excited to
recap that it's really hard to watch
week to week but
you do what you do and i mean it would
have been nice like back in the day if
we had watched downton week two week and
we could have been part of the downton
conversation so it's it's cool to you
know
experience part of something
to be a part of something exactly
um
so yeah oh today also my episode on
sophia's podcast dropped sophia with an
f she was on the toast yesterday the
reception was so positive i'm so glad
and then i did her podcast um which airs
today so check that out i started
listening to it this morning while i was
getting ready but i haven't gotten to
your segment yet i was um i started from
the top and so i'm really excited about
that it was so far so good and i'm
excited to hear what you ladies chat
about i don't even remember that was
like that day was such a blur so maybe i
need to listen to it again also to
remind myself of how funny and
charismatic i was according to this
description you talk about say yes to
the dress oh i do yeah
that's so i'll never stop laughing at
say yes to the dress content i'm so glad
like someone's enjoying it my trauma i
mean everyone's enjoying it it was just
on it just aired the other day yeah it
just re-aired which like is really a
trigger point for me
i'm sorry but we all enjoy it i'm glad
that everyone can you know laugh at me
yeah laugh at your pain yeah pretty much
pretty much
um okay well we could jump right in if
you have nothing else that you want to
share with the class on this beautiful
thursday
no you just want to launch right in yeah
i'm good are you good i'm good yeah we
have some some good stories so i think
without further a
do
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
the pill club do you need to renew your
birth control prescription switch your
birth control maybe try it for the first
time whether you know the brand you want
or you want help finding the best option
the pill club medical team has your back
the pill club offers birth control
subscriptions prescribed by a medical
professional and delivered straight to
your door for free they offer over 120
fda approved brands and they ship to all
50 states
most brands of birth control are free
with insurance or medicaid otherwise the
prices start as low as seven dollars a
month without insurance the pill club
delivers birth control to your door for
free in discreet packaging along with
fun self-care gifts and goodies and
right now when you go to thepillclub.com
toast the pill club is offering a 10
donation to bedsider.org for every
morning toast listener who becomes a
patient your donation will help
low-income individuals get access to
birth control through bedsider.org
that's thepillclub.comtoast
to get your first birth control care
package and donate to help more women in
need of affordable birth control
remember that's thepillclub.com toast
and you must use that link to make the
donation
go through
and today's episode is also brought to
you by manscaped roses are red violets
are blue we love to shave balls how
about you valentine's day is coming and
we know the gift to give the special
someone in for any and all occasions
this valentine's day it's time to give
him a gift that four million men
worldwide trust from manscaped
who are the leaders in below the waist
grooming and of course we've got a
special offer when you go to
manscape.com and use code toast you can
get 20 off and free shipping so we've
got tons of mans escaped products in our
house ben loves them
um we have the performance package 4.0
it's really the gift that every guy
needs in their life to make each and
every day just a little more special the
product he's going to love in this
package is the lawnmower 4.0 it's like
their electric trimmer and it's designed
to trim the hair on loose skin if you
know what i mean and their advanced skin
safe technology reduces cuts and nicks
on his delicate areas like his balls it
even has a 4000k led light so we can
shave anywhere your heart desires
it's also waterproof so you can use it
in the shower and the sink it's really
kind of everything of the sort they have
tons of other products too like really
great travel cases and different types
of serums um and also they have boxer
briefs so everything manscaped makes is
just like perfect for the man in your
life it's a really cute gift for
valentine's day and if you go to
manscape.com our exclusive offer of 20
off and free shipping is with the code
toast get 20 off and free shipping with
the code toast at manscaped.com
gift his cupid an arrow from manscaped
this valentine's day his balls will
thank you manscape.com code toast
that's the perfect valentine's day gift
look no further let's just call off the
search it's manscaped it's over
okay our first story some big news kim
kardashian is on the cover of vogue this
month which is always a huge deal
especially i feel like we all feel how
big of a deal it is for her even though
it's happened now a number of times it's
just always very exciting she says i've
chosen myself and now she's taking us
inside her new world the photos are
stunning i'm sure everyone saw the
photos of the kids styled by north being
the cutest [ __ ] campers
and the interview um there's some you
know highlights
that people are sharing she's talking
about her 40s she said quote my 40s are
about being team me i'm going to eat
well i'm going to work out i'm going to
have more fun spend more time with my
kids and the people who make me happy
and i feel like that's exactly what
we're seeing from kim um in the last
year and going forward
and
other than that i mean the interview was
like a little
boring there wasn't like any bombshell
she didn't even acknowledge like pete
but it was just kind of it's it's really
just like a benchmark of where she is in
her life right now like first of all the
pictures were
stunning she looked gorgeous and i loved
that she had the kids in them the little
anecdote that it was styled by north was
one of the cutest things of all time the
pictures of the kids are so sick her
kids are gorgeous like really stunning
and yeah while the interview definitely
was like lackluster i feel like it's
really evident of where she is in her
life right now like we've been seeing
her and like
what she described for like the season
that she's in in her life in this
article is exactly how i i perceive it
like she's so authentic she really is
just like putting herself first for the
first time in so long i feel like it was
always like kanye and the kids and her
family and just like her career and now
it's like she just wants to enjoy
being a mom being a businesswoman like
being a queen and i i feel that
radiating from her aura
yeah for sure and i just want to say
like the interview with zach lester like
not uh for any fault of kim's just like
i
from the interviewer's point of view
like sharing with us like anecdotes and
like you know the way that these um
centerfold stories are often written
it's like just so
cliche sometimes like seeing her in her
natural habitat like you would never
guess this is the most famous woman in
the world it's like how many [ __ ]
times are we going to read that about a
person especially right it's almost like
celebrities are people too yeah no and
that's always like where they go with it
and not that i was like expecting like a
blockbuster article but again like
really no new information
from the kardashian front for the stands
maybe for people who are like regular
people who don't you know live up kim's
butt but for those of us who do it's
like we know all of these things that
kim is like the nicest person that she's
so sweet on time
yeah like
we've we've been known
we've been known 100 those of us who
permanently reside up here took us
um courtney was quoted in the article
quite a bit it was cute i mean i
i love to see him on the cover of vogue
i think her journey with vogue has been
so interesting
like her first vogue cover which was
like widely criticized was her and kanye
i don't know who did her makeup but they
should be fired immediately like there
was so much and there was a whole
episode on it remember in the
kardashians yeah um and now this is just
like her i don't know how many times but
it's been many and i'm just so proud of
her like i just love her yeah i think
every time that she gets the cover of
u.s vogue it's an achievement and i also
don't think there is a higher honor in
the fashion world
so
we'll just keep doing
it right now and i think just from like
a market like i know there's you know
really like snobbish people in fashion
who are like kim on the cover of vogue
oh my god clutching their pearls um
but from a marketing perspective like
homegirl is selling way more copies than
anyone else and there's a reason she's
the most famous person in the world so
i love it
love it happy for her like you know how
the happy this makes her and that makes
the fans really happy so um we always
love to get kim content and we got fam
stuff too so it's all good
and she's wearing skims which is just so
great for her billion dollar brand but
think about like
billions when you think about um kim
always talks about you know when she
went to the mecca for the first time she
was kanye's plus one like she like was a
guest and she like was not welcome
really and connie was really the one who
like introduced her to the fashion world
and now she like literally runs it it's
just crazy
yeah it's crazy well speaking of kanye
that's a great segue into our next story
because um
kanye and julia fox are rumored to be in
an open relationship and also julia fox
was on call her daddy this week i hadn't
had a chance to watch it until yesterday
and i have so many thoughts and
assessments on
on this girl who i really like did not
know first of all i'm cracking up
because when she first came on the scene
we were like this would be like if
snitch started dating kanye like this
like toasty right
no no no no no that's not it that's not
who she is she is not i mean i i had no
preconceived notions of her but if i had
to describe her first of all i think she
looks a lot like um michelle
trachtenberg
given that she is the real life version
of georgina from gossip girl like her
her
upbringing like she's born and bred in
new york like started going to clubs at
14 like committing crimes doing drugs
all of these things like she is georgina
like i couldn't make it
i couldn't separate the two and she has
just lived like this extremely intense
extreme artistic life and i feel like
what she's doing now with kanye is like
the role she was born to play i don't
know how kanye found like how these two
found each other because they're so well
matched in the sense of what they're
trying to do and i know that like
they're in a relationship but like i
really and
she was asked like what do you think
about people who say that this
relationship is fake and she said you
know time will tell which is also people
do people think their relationship is
fake i don't i haven't heard i don't i
don't think that they're
like in love or falling in love no me
neither but i don't think this is like a
staged relationship i think this is like
performance art based on like everything
that she was saying like i think for
for kanye like he loves having like a
muse she's so like
interesting to look at and she's so
fashioned and she's been fashion and
she's been art and that's her like
career trajectory and she's an actress
so she's just like playing this role
and i think that works really well for
connie because he gets to like flex his
fashion muscles and he loves doing that
he did it with kim and he did it with
amber rose and i think for her like
being in this
sort of like
almost it's almost like an improv thing
you know is exactly it's role-playing
it's playing and that's like a lot of
what she did uh before she was an
actress like she was a dominatrix which
she was explaining was how like she got
her start in acting because you're
really just like putting on a
persona so i think like being kanye's
muse and like stepping out the way that
they are is everything that like she's
done in her life put together as well so
like the acting the fashion the art the
intensity like i
don't see these two and i don't even
think for one second the way she was
talking about him there was didn't sound
like butterflies in the air or anything
just like this is an extremely cool
experience
they do to call each other boyfriend and
girlfriend but i just think they're
too like
busy they're in a business together i
know what you mean it's like a really
mutually beneficial relationship
yeah and i think they both think it's so
cool they think the other is so cool
they have a lot of respect for the other
person and i'm sure that they do like
hang out one-on-one and have a nice time
but i don't think that they're like head
over heels in love or anything like that
and she she didn't say that they were
she didn't say that they weren't but
that's the vibe i'm getting that this is
like you know live performance art and
what did she have to say about kim
so she
she talked a bit about like how she
wasn't gonna like you know disrespect
like a 10-year relationship by like
commenting on this or that but she also
talked about how a lot of people like
compare her and kim because they've worn
a lot of the same things but like even
when julia was wearing
those things like she knew kim had worn
them because like kim is an icon but she
was mostly coming from like the place of
like
kim wears a lot of blends yeah like i
wear a lot of tiago but that's like both
of us being influenced by kanye
okay i don't think people really compare
her and kim i don't think so either but
i don't know if what i read like i don't
i
i don't think i'm reading what everyone
else is reading yeah because you know
what i mean i haven't heard that this is
like a fake relationship or and i don't
think that anyone is really comparing
her and kim i think people are very
intrigued by this relationship because
it's so fast it's so public it's so
weird he's like posting on instagram i
want my family back and then he has a
girlfriend like he's spotted out with
other women it's bizarre so i think
people are intrigued but i don't think
people are like you know who's better
kim or julia like it's not a competition
no i don't think that's they're
the same at all and
so i wasn't even so
curious about how she feels about him
and plus we've heard from on her podcast
like she is a kardashian
and i don't think she would say anything
that's going to get her
tripped up or in trouble she doesn't
like want to be that person and
considering like her and kanye it
doesn't feel like
you know artists a great big love it's
not like she's needing to be like well
he's not with kim anymore and he's with
me right well you know what like this is
a cr this is like a once in a lifetime
thing to happen to some girl you know
like
kanye
is that guy like he can make anyone into
anything and he's you know has these
muses and those muses go on to do
amazing things so i'm just glad it
sounds like she's just like here for the
ride for the journey she like knows how
crazy it is
but like she's living for it
yes and
this was the role she was born to play
like everything in her life leading up
to now
is like
all encompasses what she's doing with
kanye like being this like out and about
girl taking fashion risks like she's not
she's just honestly not shy she's not
yeah no and she was even talking about
how like she now people like think she's
in all these spaces and like uh with all
these famous people and and that she is
just very much like i've earned my spot
here like even when they were hanging
out with madonna she was like i invited
i set up that dinner and i invited kanye
got it you know she's not like a rando
right like straggler but she is like a
very like niche art fashion girly yes
and
that's exactly what kanye loves so
also
it's so the whole thing is so weird but
she said told this really funny anecdote
that you remember when she was wearing
the eye shadow
that everyone was like making fun of
well she said like there was one time
where kanye wanted to put like a line
across her nose to make it look like
sunglasses
and she was like no that's like a that's
a step too far i don't want that but i
was thinking about it i was like that
would actually be so cool well then it
would like make sense like yeah like
trying to do like
sunglasses
and also if they did the line like going
out all the way like i just thought that
was a cool idea and sometimes that's why
you gotta let kanye do his thing hunter
we're here and she said that she was
like i should have let him do it oh okay
okay yeah we respect a queen who knows
when she's wrong
yeah i just thought that was funny maybe
i'll try it i just think this is like
the craziest social experiment
it is and i just i don't know how long
it lasts for neither does she
go from here jax where do we go
i don't know
i don't know it's a crazy time
it's a crazy time for
the devolution of kim yay
and then like when the pete of all and
all it's just like it's a wild time
it's a lot for me do let me know
dude let me know if you want me to come
over and help you with your sunglasses
made out of eyeshadow because i would be
willing to help
maybe we'll do it for a patreon
when you do my makeup
if you ever do when that day never comes
yeah
okay are you ready for our next story
yeah i'm ready for the next story
great
very sad update bob saggett has died due
to head trauma his family confirms one
month after he was found dead in the
orlando hotel so we're getting a bit of
news and update here one month after the
full house star was found dead on
january 9th at the ritz carlton in
orlando florida his family confirmed in
a statement to people that he died due
to head trauma they said the authorities
have determined that bob passed away
from head trauma they have concluded
that he accidentally hit the back of his
head on something thought nothing of it
and went to sleep no drugs or alcohol
were involved
so i've actually been like really
curious and waiting for a follow-up on
bob saget because people had said it was
a heart attack because there was
immediately published there was no foul
play
no drug or alcohol abuse and so where do
we go from here i assumed it was a heart
attack that's what i had read somewhere
um
and this like closing the chapter and
having this be the
the cause of death is like not
satiating at all you know it's like
it's such a tragedy in the sense that
like it was so like these things happen
all the time and people don't die
yeah no like a terrible terrible
accident yeah and
it just it breaks the heart to hear
that this is
how he went and it reminds me of billy
mays
what happened to him again
he was on an airplane if you guys don't
know the og oxiclean guy ever we all
knew
he was on an airplane like taking down
an overhead and got hit in the head with
one of the suitcases thought nothing of
it went home went to sleep and never
woke up
oh my god
yeah this is like you have to be really
careful when you bump your head
especially if it's like you think maybe
you're fine you have a headache no it's
like that's like a really scary thing
and that's why they remember when we
were kids like you would hit your head
you couldn't go to bed for 30 minutes
like yeah of course
it's real yeah yeah
damn this story is just so sad i mean
it's so terrible still even it's been
like a month in the outpouring of like
love and just bob sag attributes like
they keep coming in
and i hope now just having a cause of
death like gives his family some peace
but still it's like i just feel like
this is not the the cause of death that
brings peace it's like ugh like so could
have avoided this like if only this
yeah exactly so sad and his wife just
keeps posting like really cute videos of
them and it's just like
it's like it's one of the worst stories
ever
yeah
agreed so just wishing his family like
love and i hope this brings him some
sort of closure yeah
are you ready for our next story some
make happy news if it's happy news
that's brought to you by bowling branch
it is
no one wants to cut corners on what's
important and few things matter more
than a good night's rest bowling
branch's signature sheets feel so soft
and light you'll forget you're not
actually sleeping on a cloud and if
they're and they're sustainably made for
uncompromising quality from field to
factory so i don't know if you guys can
see behind me my entire bed is bowling
branch i made the decision to go bowling
branch over a year ago and i never
looked back their sheets are the softest
organic sheets on the market they get
better with every wash and comfort isn't
their only standard all of their
products are a hundred percent made of
sustainable raw materials and as the
first fair trade commission manufacturer
of linen you can feel as good about your
bowling brand sheets as they feel
against your skin
so the product that i have is this
signature hemmed sheets from bowling
branch it's their best seller they're
buttery soft organic cotton in a classic
sateen weave for sheets that get softer
over time my favorite part is that
they're not too hot or too cold it's the
perfect year-round sheets for most
sleepers and they focus on quality over
quantity there's no inflated thread
counts here because more isn't always
better they come in beautiful colors in
all sizes from twin up to california
king and they're made to a higher
standard there's nothing worse than a
fitted sheet that doesn't fit so bowling
branch offers 17
inch deep fitted sheets and labeled
sides to help you make your bed
beautifully every time remember i told
you i was having like this journey with
me and ben waking up every morning and
our fitted sheet was like in a ball at
the bottom of the bed yes
so the bowling branch fitted sheets are
just like they feel custom it's such a
game changer that doesn't happen anymore
and it was so annoying we like couldn't
figure it out um they also give you a
fair price and a 30 day risk free trial
with free shipping and returns
experience the best sheets you've ever
felt at bowlingbranch.com get 15 off
your first set of sheets when you use
the promo code toast at checkout that's
bowl and branch b-o-l-l-a-n-d
branch.com promo code toast
love it
sounds so good to get into bed right now
you're just
i love to bed you guys know
you're speaking to me
okay our next story some exciting news
snoop dogg is thrilled to be the owner
of death row records the label that
launched his career that is so exciting
the 50 year old rap icon which is
hmm
i also read something about snoop dogg
today
oh okay so let's do this and then you'll
want to share
yeah he was sued for alleged uh sexual
assault and battery so i just figured we
should give a full picture of what's
going on with snoop dogg of snoop dogg's
day today okay the 50 year old i can't
purchase death row records from
recording and music publishing company
mr
mnrk music group which is funded by the
investment firm blackstone the company's
announced and released on wednesday
quote i'm thrilled and appreciative of
the opportunity to acquire the iconic
and culturally significant death row
records brand which has immense untapped
future value he said in the release it
feels good to have ownership of the
label i was part of at the beginning of
my career and as one of the founding
members so that's pretty cool to like
have
joined a music label when you're
starting up and have so much success
that you eventually purchase it
you know that's like us buying aol
yeah something like that
no that's cool but there is more news
with um snoop dogg today so please share
a woman alleges that snoop dogg and his
associate bishop don magic juan sexually
assaulted her after a show in 2013 snoop
dogg denies the claim
so he's being sued for alleged sexual
assault of a woman in anaheim california
in 2013
tmz's reporting and documents are viewed
by pitchfork pitchfork to confirm the
woman who's an actor model and dancer
identified as jane doe says that she
attended a snoop dogg concert on may of
29th of that year and in the lawsuit
jane doe alleges that snoop dogg's
associate bishop don magic juan
took her to his home against her will
and the following morning removed his
penis from his pants quote and forced
his penis into her mouth the next day
according to the lawsuit juan allegedly
took doe jane doe to snoop dogg's studio
where snoop dogg is said to have
cornered her in a bathroom stall and
first forced her into oral sex snoop
dogg allegedly quote proceeded to
masturbate and ejaculate on jane doe's
upper chest and lower neck jane doe is
suing snoop dogg for a violation of the
trafficking victims protection act for
sexual battery and for sexual assault in
addition to snoop dogg and bishop don
magic juan the lawsuit names the
defendants the companies uh gerber and
co the broadest collection casa verde
capital and mary jane events snoop dogg
has denied jane doe's claims pitchfork
has emailed his representatives for
comments so and he's also
scheduled to be in the super bowl
this week oh my god yeah i'm curious if
um
everyone's gonna you know walk the walk
when they talk to talk about you know
me too and time's up and stuff
right oh my god i didn't even think
about that
yeah
wow that is
wild
yeah that is wild i thought that was the
story you were bringing up and i was
like oh never mind no i i had seen like
so much news about like how just
monumental it is that he's buying this
record company that he um
started started got his start at but
i mean that would have been a nice story
if it weren't for the other story i saw
i think this morning right oh wow okay
and that's a really kind of graphic
story that she tells so um
very curious to see what if anything
happens
yeah
agreed
oh wow um
and how it affects the super bowl this
weekend which i forgot was this weekend
yeah i mean i can't watch i have a show
and i really do like love the super bowl
just because i love the commercials and
i love the food um but we're gonna be
having fun in boston drinking spritzes
so like i guess it's okay
that is okay and we're not gonna be able
to recap the super bowl
oh my god that's so bad like that's so
us you know i know like how will you
guys know who won the super bowl if we
don't do the toast on monday morning i
don't know
damn who do you think it's going to be
who's it against
rams versus bengals we're rooting for
the bank for the bagels but i think it's
going to be the rams that's what i said
too
but also you know ever since we were
like just
we were talking about like nice things
that you know
things we've heard about different
players but of course every player has a
story and a journey and when we were
talking about the rams and all these
different teams i got so many messages
about different um
players on both teams so both teams are
filled with really good people who want
to win
um
but
there actually is a crazy story about
the
the quarterback for the rams so he and
his wife have like been together since
college are so cute kelly she's a
podcaster
yes i i meant to bring this up because
you kind of slammed him the last time we
talked about him slam him i don't know
him you slammed him like incredibly you
went hard i guess
i don't know i forget but it was like
and i forgot in that moment that he is
married to kelly and she has a podcast
and they live in um
yeah and she likes apparently spells
like so much like fun tea about life
there and people just love them and um
that's the point in the rams column
i know when i believe she went through
like a really difficult time with a
brain tumor and they were just like the
beacon of hope for each other so i think
he is like you know that guy and i think
they are that couple for a reason
okay so either way
we all win we all win i agree
we all win because jackson mahomes is
not at the super bowl
and neither is austin
no well you never know austin could show
up it is la maybe they'll take snoop
dogg out of the halftime show and put in
austin
perhaps i don't even want to know what
it's like on the ground in l.a this
weekend like trying to get to tickets
like every thirst monster on the planet
running even at like the restaurants
clubs etc like if everyone is in la this
weekend like the traffic the traffic
yikes yikes
are you ready for our fifth and final
story i am and i'm not going to sing
today i've sung two days in a row i
think it's enough don't push your luck
but you should have my voice
you have to sing tomorrow
for the final story i'm preparing an
arrangement of sorts oh i'm so excited
okay this fifth and final story is like
really um it's pretty disturbing
patrick wilson who we love morning glory
i will not i heard this story this man
has been like one of my celebrity
crushes
for years until now and now the thought
of coming close to him makes me want to
puke
patrick wilson is shocking the world
with his canine confession he says quote
i've eaten dog poop
i feel like he like said this and
expected people to be like oh yeah that
happened to me one time too like it's
it's a dog owner thing and everyone's
just like get the [ __ ] away from me
yeah no he thought it was like toe
secret and yeah it's not like that or
like you know you know when people like
they confess something like you know
like i kind of like the smell of my own
farts and a couple other people are like
yeah me too it's like a human thing i
think he thought that's what was gonna
happen here and absolutely nobody
corroborated his story no it's like that
scene in mean girls where they're all
admitting stuff and they all catch each
other and then like you go a hair too
far and you fall on your back and that's
patrick wilson yeah so he was
interviewed by empire magazine and they
asked him um what's the worst thing
you've put in your mouth and he said
quote it's probably dog [ __ ]
i'm sure in my quest to pick up dog crap
that i've licked the bag to open the bag
and then it's on my hand and i have dog
[ __ ] in there too
and then when asked about his least
favorite smell he also brought up his
beloved canines he said you're talking
to a guy that spends a good portion of
the week cleaning up dog [ __ ] in his
yard but i'm sort of immune to that now
okay i mean a lot of people have a lot
of dogs it seems as though he has three
dogs and
they managed to raise those dogs all
their lives without ever eating their
duty
yeah or even like thinking about like
did i accidentally eat duty no oh this
sounds like a
chill down my spine
also the idea of like licking your
finger to open the bag like i'll never
for five minutes it takes forever to
open that bag i have time i have time
today i have the time it never even
occurred to me to lick it that is
so
twisted and disgusting
and
i'm gonna ask the question i think i
know the answer but does anyone relate
to this has anyone experienced something
similar
or are we just are we the outliers here
because this is twisted
it is so twisted um
[ __ ] it reminds me of that scene in
succession sort of when cousin greg is
taking like snacks from the office in a
poop bag and tom is like that's a poop
bag and it's like well it's a bag for
poop but it's not like there's no poop
in it yet
but there might be it's meant for poop
plus don't the manufacturers put like
poop chemicals on it so that you know to
conceal the smell they're not just like
well i guess there's there could be some
bags that are scented some that are just
like plastic i guess but like if i was
feeling really sick like i was gonna
vomit and i had to either vomit in my
hands or open up one of theo's duty bags
and vomit in it like i think i'd vomit
in my hands of course yeah duty bags are
just reserved for dude wait duty bags
with a duty in it or not no oh oh
without a duty in it i would rather
vomit it to me it's just not a plastic
bag i can't explain it i've never
thought of it like that
yeah
me neither this is a lot of duty combo
we always take it back to duty and i
mean i'm all for celebrities like being
authentic and upfront and honest but i
do feel like there is a line and i do
i want to say i think that patrick
wilson crossed the line
i think so too and i don't know if you
can uncross a line
and especially because this isn't a man
who makes news a lot like he's in some
big movies he's not real like he's a
judy greer like he's in everything but
like no one really knows him he's in it
like for the he's like an actor he's not
a celebrity really so it's not like we
see headlines about him every day
that'll wash us down the news cycle like
this is gonna be the top of his google
search for a while and it's gonna be the
thing that people associate with him
like i didn't know anything about this
man's personal life until this and now
it's the only thing that i know and i
wish i could and that's something he's
gonna have to live with the consequences
of his actions
yeah i guess considering like no one's
ever really like
cared so much i i i'm sure he's shocked
that this is getting so much
so embarrassing yeah
beyond
well those are the fast five stories i
feel as though you needed to know them
and now we can launch into our tv recap
because uh real houses of orange county
was on last night pretty good episode
i'm looking forward to your thoughts yes
the tv recap is brought to you by
movement watches valentine's day is
already around the corner and we know
that finding the right gift can be
stressful that's why our friends over at
movement watches have already done the
hard work for you with a huge sitewide
sale movement is a valentine's day
favorite with timeless watches 18 carat
fine jewelry pieces and special edition
styles like rare ceramic watches and
bracelets you can save on these gifts
right now just choose a watch and a
matching accessory and get an immediate
20 off your order plus free shipping and
returns always enjoy a stress-free
valentine's day by curating the perfect
watch and accessory for a special
discount all in one
and done gifting made easy shop 20 off
with free shipping and free returns by
going to movement.com toast go to
movement.com toast for your most
stress-free valentine's day gift yet and
movement is spelled mvmt so it's
mvmt.com
toast for the 20 off with free shipping
and free returns movement styles
shouldn't break the bank join the
movement
okay real housewives of orange county we
finished up in mexico noella was just
like on one i couldn't even like look
her she was being so annoying um and
when the women get back to new york
there's a bunch of like really cute
activities and i thought that the night
on shannon's boat and the hibachi like
looked like such a fabulous get-together
no it looked so nice i was sad that gina
wasn't there because that was like what
the evening needed and i i'm sure she
was like busy or something but her
absence was but the boat wasn't that big
i don't actually don't think she could
have been invited
but
i guess but then she couldn't i guess
shannon wanting to invite heather
because like they need to you know move
forward in their relationship and emily
and shane when i saw shannon opened the
door for emily and shane and like
shannon and shane hugged i was like
these people know each other i thought
the same thing and if you look shannon
didn't even like fully put her arm
around change she like hovered over his
back with her hand i thought this is so
weird i saw this same thing i was like
what do these two people talk about i
don't think that they do but no the
evening was so beautiful like activities
wise it was beautifully planned it was
hysterical like the boat and shannon
being you know the coxswain and then
they had hibachi which i know was like
your dream but i also thought the
conversation at the table was just like
good deep meaningful conversations
adult like people are sharing people are
being open it's like not surface level
and i was just like this sounds like
this is you know goal like 40
something year old goals to have an
evening like that of like you know good
fun good food and good convo
i completely agree i also thought
i feel like every time i see terry and
heather like out of their comfort zone
like not at their house on their terms i
just feel like awkward i can't explain
it
it's like a dog walking on its hind legs
legs you just never know school you
never know how they're gonna behave and
even when she like came on the boat and
like i was like what is she gonna drink
from this boat and there was champagne i
was like okay we're covered like i agree
it's very funny to see them out of their
element because they you know everything
is so controlled with them
with them yeah and also i think part of
the reason why she didn't invite gina is
because we talk about this next week
like it's clear that shannon is like
very threatened by heather's
relationship with gina and like when she
finds out they're going to new york
together next week she like starts to
cry at lunch um so i have to assume that
was like some sort of reasoning
yeah i love heather's friendship with
gina and i understand what she's saying
about it's just like easy to get along
with her and i feel like people feel
that way about other people and the
issue with housewives is so often you
don't feel that and you're like trying
to like force these connections that
aren't there but when two people just
hit it off and you don't have to like
question whatever what someone is saying
like every single thing that they say
it's like are you saying this to hurt me
like what is your motive it's just like
nice to click with someone and not have
to like constantly look over your
shoulder
i also love that they went back to the
quiet woman and they referenced the
evening the owner was like we'll get you
a paper plate like that is a gorgeous
bistro i would love to go yeah no the
food sounded so good like the muscles
with whatever sauce i'll have a heaping
pile of those as well
yeah it was just like a fun evening
noella obviously had to ruin it just
like by being herself um which was sad
but like
i don't know she's just like really
bothering me
and
i'm having a hard time like giving her
my sympathies you know like in
housewives if someone's going through a
really hard time like you really feel
like we gave shannon a pass for a while
teresa gets a pass all the time um
and i don't know like she's just so
not making herself sympathetic
yeah no i i don't have sympathy first of
all those women got you know sympathy
because like we knew them before we went
through this with them and we wanted to
see them come out the other side like we
don't know noella from adam so for you
to show up with all of this baggage and
the way that she's handling so much of
it is just so deranged even the thing
with like the stack of vaginas which was
just so bizarre so emily says
jen told us you got a stack of vaginas
for your wedding and noella's like why
doesn't jen talk about her own life
first of all that's all she's doing why
did you tell jen she's like
and it's not like it's something that
you told jen in confidence because you
guys like aren't even friends and she i
didn't think it was weird that jen
shared that with the other girls that's
like not
god it didn't sound like a secret the
two of you don't have secrets you're not
even close so like if it's something
that you tell jen then it's something
that emily and shannon can know and then
when shannon's like how does it make you
feel that jen told us this it's like
what are your producer producer plant
literally
it was too heavy-handed and also the
stack of vaginas thing was just like
so bizarre funny like i don't know i
just find nothing noella does to be like
funny or quirky or like cute i just i'm
not buying whatever it is that noel is
selling and she's just really starting
to annoy me yeah no she's been annoying
me and she continues to but her looks
are just top tier looks the glam the
hair everything it's it's top housewife
glam it really is and even when she's
like not in glam she's always perfection
it's it is it's true it's it's it's a
beautiful thing to me it counts for a
lot it does
and then the weirdest part and kind of
the climax was of the episode was after
you know jen got some good wedding
advice marriage advice from heather she
decided to ambush her husband on camera
um
and i think like the fact that he they
didn't maybe he did say it and it wasn't
aired but the fact that like
no mention of the camera obviously makes
rhyme look like a prick but i think they
this is probably a conversation they
really need to have as a couple and
having it on camera for the first time
is no place to do it
not at all and i actually felt like in
the beginning when she sat down with him
like he was kind of being a team
player she was like you say this but i
need you to say more than that like like
tell me more about how my day was good
and productive and he like sat there
like a child like trying to answer the
question correctly and like he he and i
didn't think he was being facetious i
think he was just like doing as he was
told he was being like he was obeying
yeah and then i think he got to his wits
and he's like i'm not doing this on
camera because it's it's pretty awkward
and also like i when jen describes their
situation to heather i get it and i get
that there neither of them feel
appreciated they've both made sacrifices
they're both envious of the sac like
what the other has she wants to be home
more like he wants to be out more etc
but then when she sat him down and like
tried to explain the issues to him i was
like
this feels like a reach
you know i just didn't see she wasn't
aligning the problems she told heather
to the problem she told ryan which is it
like do you not feel appreciated or do
you guys just have like a dynamic you
need to work out because that's what you
told heather i think it's like this it's
like she doesn't feel appreciated so she
tells ryan she doesn't feel appreciated
and he says i appreciate you and then
she's
she just doesn't like feel it and like
you know what i mean it's like you can
say all the right things but it's just
like they're they're not connected
and so and that's not something that's
going to be achieved on on camera and
also like i felt a little bit you know
like with the like she might have been a
little tipsy and the conversation was
just going [ __ ] nowhere i just like
wasn't rooting for her went up until
recently i didn't love her in the
beginning but with every episode i'm
like you know she's growing on me she's
like actually smart and i like her
relationship with heather and then like
she sat down with her husband and i'm
like shut up like i just i just wasn't
rooting for her at all and especially
after last week when she was crying in
the gym and like i was crying i was so
here for her i was ready for her to come
home and talk to ryan and put him in his
place but then like i i i'm neither team
jen nor ryan so it was very
confusing to me to feel like so
sympathetic towards her and then be like
wait why are we crying again agreed and
she continued that like chaotic messy
nature on watch robin's live last night
i had to call you immediately because i
just watched the first few minutes um
just to see what she was about and to
see how she like came off and watch what
i'm inside because ever since lars i
just realized it's such a great audition
i could fall in love with a housewife
and i was so physically uncomfortable
with my cringe that i had to call you
and like it was i don't think i watched
more than five minutes but it was so
painful painful she was just like
speaking gibberish like annie asked her
question and she was just like
she was saying english words but they
did not have any meaning like they were
just like
like what no because andy's question was
valid like how much of your argument
with your husband had to do with the
fact that he didn't want to do it on
camera not that he didn't want to do it
at all and she's like
well
dude
so i was like what
i didn't even make it to that question
the only questions i heard were
why is his name ryan when it's ryan oh
you know what her answer was
this was literally her answer she's like
when i met him his name was ryan then he
told me his name was ryan and we would
meet other people and he would say ryan
and i was like where is the egg what
like what does it answer the question
what the [ __ ] is his name right and then
the other question that was asked was
about the stack of vaginas and it was
clear that she was trying to be funny
that's she's trying to be funny and that
she hadn't watched the episode because
she was like well what does that even
look like which is what we were all
wondering until you saw the [ __ ]
picture and she was like is it
horizontal is it vertical and it's like
watch the episode oh i didn't think that
maybe she hadn't seen the episode
because yeah like i was curious yeah
what's the stack of vaginas look like
too and then i saw the picture i'm like
oh look there's a stack of vaginas so i
had no more questions after that about
what it looked like and
she was like is it like side side side
like stack stack stack or like a card a
deck of cards like you shuffle the
vagina like she was just not being funny
like and it was bothering me and i did
turn it off right after that also when
she this is when i i literally turned it
off when she was like is it like this
this this
that's what i called you yeah and that's
when i had just turned it off and went
to bed
i'm literally dying so it was just not a
good week for dr dunn
no it really wasn't and i don't think
the episode like got much better
at all also
um
i wanted to say one more thing oh which
was when noella was like to gina like
i'm wearing my leopard like jersey and
jean and her confession was like i'm not
from germany not from jersey yeah no
like that's rude it was very rude it's
like you literally don't you wanna
listen to me
leopard is like a really unique pattern
and when someone's like i'm wearing a
leopard for you that's like it can be
insulting
everyone can pull off leopard no and it
just depends on the person really like
some people are just like animal print
people i actually would think that like
serena
yeah she loves leopard yep even i feel
like heather dubrow likes leopard i've
actually never worn leopard in my life i
don't think i'm not a leopard girly but
you can't be everything you know you
can't and you already are so many things
i'm so many things i'm like so plenty
like this that it can't also be like
animal prints so what did you think of
the gilded age
oh my god it's so
just stunning and i'm really enjoying it
still has the community theater
theatrics happening a little bit like
with the staging but it's okay they'll
they'll find their groove also i feel
like some of the sets like they're just
so big they're a little bit like um
cavernous
you know it's not like an intimate it's
not like the kitchen at downton where
we're like all cozy up it's like a big
fake kitchen but i think that's also
like the sign of the times they were
building these enormous like huge
cavernous homes and
that's how it felt so i'm loving the
show i'm loving the cast of characters i
mean the plot twist with the um
morrises and the things
yeah was just really crazy if only like
mr fan is very handsome i know and then
i didn't even realize that like that
their wives are so different in age that
like they have different aged husbands
yeah yeah i guess i didn't realize that
either because he was really young i
thought he was someone's secretary
me too i was like who's handsome here
yeah he's up and coming yeah is it her
son maybe um so obviously mr russell was
gonna save those guys right the aldermen
i think he was going to make a deal with
him yeah because also does he even was
he was that always his plan to like push
them to the edge so that they came to
the table embarrass them like the way
that they embarrassed him and his wife
yeah and i for an eye [ __ ] or if he
took this all the way like does he have
a bigger plan
well if he took it all the way owning
all the shares that he bought while the
company was down like he would then be
like a he would be a publicly owned
company where he owns a majority like he
would be a billion beyond billionaire
right
yeah but not if there's no station
so he like didn't need the aldermen to
come around yeah um
so it was like sad the way that it ended
up especially considering he's like
going to have mercy on them or is he i
don't know next week i think he is i
think he is but like is the town like
they so they are now in a position of
power the russells but when everyone
finds out that mr morris committed
suicide because of mr russell like are
they gonna hate the russells and then
they're gonna be outcasts again are
people gonna fear them and then respect
them you know
yeah i imagine it's a little bit of both
because still like the fans and all
those other men like they do need
russell to come around so i don't know
how far they'll push him out
yeah
um
girl across the street mary and brooke
she's a bit of pain in the ass
um i do like
i do like the dynamics inside her home
like with her aunts and i just find it
all very interesting but she herself i'm
like
shut up like she's just annoying me
oh i think she's cute i agree i love the
aunties and like to see that aunt
agnes
is
you know because she's so like looking
around mean
but she's also clearly like looking out
and it's like who is the dowager
countess in this show i don't know yet
it also could be mrs astor who was like
here for um mr russell sort uh causing a
scene at the bazaar
no one is the dowager yet i i have yet
to meet anyone who's even remotely funny
no me too or just says wise like
everything you say is like on point
i think agnes is like completely
she's way too uh in the past
yeah
see the dowager was actually wrong about
a lot of stuff
no but she was like stubborn
yeah agnes is wrong about a lot of stuff
yeah i agree and the thing with the
doubt yeah she was always right and even
though everyone thought she was like so
old and conservative she was a forward
thinker
yeah no and she had like it was a blend
of both she
she wasn't just like dogmatic and just
chose the old way just because
yeah yeah yeah um and it's crazy there's
only three episodes so i i like it i do
it definitely it grows on you i hate
watching episode by episode but the
episodes at least are long enough it's
like watching a movie
definitely and brew loves pumpkin i
can't even tell you has theo said
anything about him
yeah he said
[Music]
it's just so stinking cute what's crazy
is that
if you think about it this show and the
show 1883 take place in the literal same
exact time and like they're so different
isn't that interesting because new york
was a bustling metropolis and like
they're going out west but it's like
look at how they're living and look at
how they're living
that's true wow you're such a history
girly
yeah and it's crazy that we're getting
like these american history shows at the
exact same time
yeah
when it rains it pours
when it rings
okay well that's really all i have to
say today um i'm wearing so much makeup
it's starting to itch you know what i
mean
yeah but you're gonna be watching if
you're watching on youtube i've been
futzing with my face the whole [ __ ]
episode it's so itchy but i have an
event to go to tonight for everyone
who's coming to the spritz society x
locks club event um should i leave my
makeup on it's it'll be 12 hours i'm
thinking maybe just taking my skin off
and keeping my eyes
that's a good idea but definitely leave
some of it on if not all of it because
you look so stunning and you're going to
a party
and i'm just so itchy like i'm dying to
scratch my face okay take off your face
take off your face you do a nice face
anyway maybe
that is the nicest thing you've ever
said so tomorrow is
your final episode
it is and i just feel like we should
wait until tomorrow to talk about it
like you know like let's not talk about
things no i know but whenever it's like
the final day i actually forget to talk
about it so it's like because i was
thinking about it this morning i was
like better to share today as opposed to
tomorrow when like i'll literally forget
and then and then i won't say i'll never
have like acknowledge the space that we
were in
that i understand that i do
like i'm i was just feeling it more
today than i probably will be tomorrow
it's all i understand now i understand
now the reason for the season
um well that's our show you guys thank
you so much for listening to the morning
toast the millennial morning show where
we deliver the past five stories that
you need to know every monday through
friday on youtube so if you're watching
this on youtube please feel free to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts we found so that's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
have radiocast box all the places
wherever you listen to podcast finesse
morning toast leave a five-star review
about a beautiful stunning and smart we
are hope you guys have an amazing
thursday and we'll see you tomorrow for
friday friday it's jackie's last friday
goodbye
bye love ya